man hat das Gefühl dass nichts vorangeht
in Deutschland ausnahmsweise sind sich
mal alle Parteien einig ja man müsste
dringend unsere Bürokratie entschlacken
überall Clemens Hengst oder wie sagt man
das so politikermäßig
unser Land ist gefesselt wir haben uns
selbst gefesselt durch sehr viel
Bürokratie in ganz besonderer deutscher
Weise
gefesselt
das saveboard ist übrigens
Umsatzsteuervoranmeldung
unsere fortschrittskoalition hatte ja
große Pläne zum Beispiel jedes Jahr
400.000 Wohnungen bauen wird natürlich
nicht klar selbst für ein popeliges
Gartenhäuschen muss man ein extrem
komplizierten Bauantrag stellen können
wir das schaffen nee wir schaffen das
nicht nein nein ein
Genehmigungsverfahren in der Industrie
kam vor 15 Jahren noch mit
durchschnittlich zwei Gutachten aus
heute sind es fünf bis zehn alle die
eine Firma gründen wollen sind völlig zu
recht sauer wenn ich nicht mehr mit
Abitur nicht mehr in der Lage bin
mich durch die Stromschnellen meiner
Verwaltung die ich bezahle die für mich
da ist mich da selber durchzulavieren
dann können
wir lassen
schönes Motto für Deutschland eigentlich
ja warum denn nicht der darf man sich
nicht wundern wenn der Staat nicht mehr
als Ermöglicher wahrgenommen wird
sondern als Gegner bei manchen Sachen
läuft das komischerweise mit der
Genehmigung hier bei diesen nervigen
E-Scootern zum Beispiel die immer quer
auf dem Fahrradweg stehen die wurden
quasi über Nacht zugelassen stellen Sie
sich mal vor die Scooter Firmen würden
arbeiten wie Behörden angenommen du
willst ein E-Scooter direkt vor deinem
Haus mieten gehst hin nimmst dir einen
Anmeldeformular aus der Box und malst
den QR-Code vom Roller ab dann fährst du
mit der Bahn zur örtlichen Filiale des
E-Scooter Anbieters am anderen Ende der
Stadt natürlich zu den Öffnungszeiten
Dienstag bis Donnerstag 11 bis 16 Uhr
dann ziehst du dir eine Nummer dann
passiert erstmal eine Weile nichts
[Musik]
und wenn Du dran bist bist du gefragt
wann brauchst du denn den Roller und du
so vor zwei Tagen wäre gut gewesen
und sie so ach schade der ist weg der
hätten sie gestern kommen müssen aber
ich sehe gerade in Düsseldorf ist einer
frei geworden danke tschüss
da fällt mir ein Liebe
Immobilienbesitzer haben sie schon ihre
Hausaufgaben gemacht ich sag nur
Grundsteuerreform ja muss bald erledigt
werden also klar die Reform war
überfällig bei der grundsteuergehalten
immer noch die Werte von 1964 im Osten
sogar von 35 aber keine Angst da kommt
jetzt keiner aus dem Finanzamt zu Ihnen
nach Hause und müsst mit dem Zollstock
die Garage aus NÖ das machen sie schön
selber er will es genau wissen Heiner
Lohner vermisst noch einmal sein
Grundstück und auch die Wohnfläche
seines Hauses damit alle Angaben korrekt
sind für die neue grundsteuererklärung
sag mal er war doch ein Knick drin
es steht auf gar keinen Fall ja schön
Bücken fürs Finanzamt der Witz ist die
Grundstücksdaten Fläche Baujahr und so
weiter die liegenden Ämtern schon lange
vor aber halte ich digital sondern hier
auf Papyrus und da hat man sich gedacht
ja das ist doch eine schöne Aufgabe für
den Bürger
so zwischen Gaskrise und im nächsten
Lockdown selbst Fachleute sagen der
Antrag ist für Normalsterbliche nicht
korrekt auszufüllen zum Glück gibt es
dafür aber mittlerweile kein Scheiß
Seminare wenn wir ein Baujahr vor 1949
haben dann tragen sie mit Zeile 13 eine
1 an
für ein unbebautes Grundstück hat trägt
bitte eine 1 ein Einfamilienhaus am 2
das Zweifamilienhaus ist eine 3
Wohnungseigentum also die
Eigentumswohnung wäre die fünf den
anredeschlüssel der wird in Zahlen
genannt genau her 02 Frau
dabei
aber ich heiße doch gar nicht Frau 03
weil so komplex ist wurde die
Abgabefrist gestern um drei Monate
verlängert klar welches Finanzamt will
den Leuten ausgerechnet die jetzt
säumnisgebühren aufbrummen hoffentlich
gewöhnt sich die Politik nicht dran dass
wir für Sie lästige Aufgaben erledigen
ich meine Möglichkeiten gibt es viele
hier zum Beispiel warum Blitzen wir uns
nicht selbst mit dem selfie-stick ach
scheiße gestern stand hier noch keiner
oder ja falls Sie ein Herzinfarkt haben
seien Sie doch bitte so nett und füllen
noch schnell den Totenschein aus
spart eine Menge Arbeit
dabei muss man sagen Deutschland hat
auch ohne den Grundsteuer Bums genug auf
dem Zettel alles dauert viel zu lange
ich sage nur Energiewende seit
Kriegsbeginn sind Windkraft Biogas und
Salat Zitat Christian Lindner
freiheitsenergien eigentlich wollten wir
unseren Bedarf bis 2030 zu 80% mit
Erneuerbaren Decken da müsste auf jedes
Dach sofort Photovoltaik woran hängt es
denn Überraschung Bürokratie haben Sie
zum Beispiel mal versucht neben einer
Kirche Solarstrom zu erzeugen ist ein
Riesenspaß die Beamten bemängeln dass
die Photovoltaikanlage auch von der
Kirche auszusehen sei allerdings müssten
sich die Gläubigen dafür bis ins
Chorgestühl empor begeben das kommt die
hin
ja das ist ja das elfte Gebot hier du
sollst keine Solarzelle neben mir auf
dem Dach haben
aber gut das war jetzt eine Anlage auf
einem Dach in einem Kaff irgendwo was
ist denn mit größeren Flächen auf dem
Land hier dieser Power in Niedersachsen
hat ordentlich investiert er könnte
hiermit über 200 Haushalte klimaneutral
mit Strom versorgen könnte wir sind
unsere jetzt Sicherung die brauchen wir
alle nur noch reindrücken und schon sind
wir im Netz das heißt sie müssten
eigentlich nur diese Hebel hochdrücken
genau dann könnten wir Strom liefern ja
dicker ja gib ihm dreh den Hahn auf ja
einfach den Hebel schieben nimm das
Putin doch es fehlt an zertifizieren die
möglich machen was im Amtsdeutsch
technischer anschlussriegel
Mittelspannung
vdearn 41 10 heißt ja die verdammte VDE
Arn
das ist ja ein Klassiker
die Bundesnetzagentur hat nämlich 2019
entschieden das Anlagen nicht erst ab
1.000 kW Leistung zertifiziert werden
müssen sondern schon ab 135 der
Bundesverband Solarwirtschaft schätzt
das aktuell 1.000 Anlagen nicht ans Netz
können also wenn sie sich morgen eine
Solaranlage aufs Dach Klöppeln wollen
was müssen Sie beachten das klären wir
jetzt
herzlich Willkommen zu eine privat
genutzte Photovoltaikanlage beantragen
und genehmigt kriegen es ist das
verdammt noch mal schwerste Quiz der
Welt
schön dass Sie dabei sind beim
photovoltaik-quiz und ich kann Ihnen
versprechen hier hat noch keiner
gewonnen
unser heutiger Kandidat der Klaus ist
trotzdem frohen Mut ja warte ich habe
erst versucht mich mit also mit meiner
Freizeit ins Thema Photovoltaik
beantragen einzuarbeiten dann habe ich
gemerkt es geht nicht zu komplex aber
dann hatte ich direkt ich habe meinen
meinen Job gekündigt meiner Frau die
Kinder gegeben bin ausgezogen lebe jetzt
in einem Kellerabteil in Brandenburg
ohne Fenster und beschäftige mich twenty
four seven damit ich kann sie alles
Fragen alles
wow da ist aber einer selbstbewusst okay
erste Frage war es eigentlich eine gute
Idee
900 unterschiedliche kommerzielle
Netzbetreiber mit jeweils eigenen
Formularen über netzeinträge von
Privatleuten entscheiden zu lassen die
Antwort ist nein das war eine Scheiße
Idee und das ist richtig
[Musik]
ja
weil wenn man sich als privatmenschte
Solarzelle aufs Dach tackert macht man
diesen Verteiler Netzbetreibern viel
Arbeit aber keinen Gewinn und dann
wundern wir uns dass die bis zu 60
seitigen Anträge auf monatelang
rumliegen sehr gut Klaus nächste Frage
welches
zusätzliche Schikane hat sich der
Gesetzgeber noch für kleine
solarstromerzeuger ausgedacht das war
natürlich die Einführung des sogenannten
zwei richtungszählers das ist im Grunde
allgemein wissen hier habe ich zunächst
nur einen zwei richtungszähler der muss
da rein diese beiden kommen raus
eigentlich würden die zwei Zähler auch
funktionieren aber es ist halt
Vorschriften muss halt rein wegen der
neuen Zähler braucht Blasen laut
Vorschrift auch noch einen neuen
Zählerschrank böse ausschaut kann ich
dann eigentlich die Anlage stilllegen
abbauen sie wird dann kein Geld mehr
bringen sondern ist sie kostet dann nur
noch Geld ja genau zwei richtungszähler
der kostet nämlich auch Miete pro Jahr
kompletter aber das kann man auch toppen
das Wissen viel Licht in manchen
netzregionen muss es eine LAN-Verbindung
geben zwischen dem solarzeller dem
Elektrozähler und dem Wasserzähler aber
keine Sau sagt dir warum es ist einfach
so ja Klaus so ein ekelhafter Streber
nächste Frage ich stelle sie mir gleich
selber wie viel Mitarbeiter braucht eine
photovoltaik-firma die Solaranlagen
verkauft nur für das Bearbeiten der
neuen Anträge
50 und das ist richtig
Firma endpal verkauft Anlagen in ganz
Deutschland und beschäftigt inzwischen
allein 50 Mitarbeiter mit Anmeldungen
bei denen mehr als 900
Netzgesellschaften
ich habe so ein Lauf 50 Mitarbeiter die
Hälfte leitet inzwischen oder
posttraumatische Belastungsstörung aha
ja ich versuche es trotzdem mal mit
einer Frage sehr gute Frage was ärgert
private solarnutzer am meisten neben den
Anträgen die Tatsache dass man nur
publica 8,2 Cent pro Kilowattstunde
bekommt für den Strom den man erzeugt
aber umgekehrt für Strom den man aus dem
Netz nimmt den normalen Marktpreis
zahlen muss in Holland zum Beispiel
läuft der Stromzähler einfach rückwärts
da wird das verrechnet aber nicht bei
uns weil wir sind ja nicht in Holland
ich habe es ihnen gesagt ich weiß alles
okay ja dann kommen wir jetzt zur
finalen Frage alles oder nicht welches
Formular brauche ich wenn ich eine
Photovoltaikanlage beantragen will
achtung auf einem Atomkraftwerk
das ist unfair da ist die Zeit um ja
wenn man sich so schlecht vorbereitet
von Wagner
[Applaus]
so Kinder ich hoffe die Kamera läuft
denn ich halte nicht an abonniert den
Kanal hier Danke euer Gernot passt nicht
so ich gehe wieder nach Hause
schönen Feierabend Jürgen ciao